patchouli cannelle rose coriandre autant
d'odeurs que nos petitsnz en herbes vont
s'amuser à reconnaître l'Osmothèque de
Versailles lieu unique au monde de
conservation du parfum propose pendant
les vacances un atelier pour enfants de
découverte des senteurs l'idée pour les
enfants c'est d'apprendre deux trois
deux trois idées sur la parfumerie de de
comprendre un petit peu d'où d'où
viennent les matières premières de la
parfumerie qu'ells peuvent en fait
eux-mêmes sentir dans la nature
découvrir que la flor d'orange est sang
la rose scle à la Vande et cetera et
puis aussi pour eux faire un exercice
vraiment ludique où ils essaient de
trouver de retrouver l'odeur qui va avec
la petite image qui leur est présentée
un programme ludique et participatif où
chaque enfant peut s'initier au monde
des senteurs en découvrant leur histoire
et en faisant travailler son nez et sa
mémoire
olfactive ce que j'aime bien c'est
sentir les odeurs et en découvrir j'ai
découvert celle du
muget celle de l'Est
et celle de la fleur d'oranger pour
maintenir en éveil l'odorat des enfants
rien de tel que de susciter leur intérêt
et leur curiosité un exercice que
certains pratiquent déjà au quotidien
grâce à notre odorat et ben on peut
reconnaître les différents pas les
différents goûts est-ce que c'est
quelque chose que tu faisais déjà à la
maison ou quand tu te promènes dehors
bah je le faisais souvent l'atelier
d'une durée d'unh30 est accessible aux
enfants âgés de 8 à 11 ans
en dehors des vacances scolaires les
petitsnz peuvent aussi se retrouver les
mercredis